harry potter it who comes up with the
name like that okay and welcome to this
video by the way so we got a spanish
opening the ring and that line I I
really have to look this up now yeah I
get this so often it's not a good line
at all over white and I tend to have
problems because I'm yeah I forget how
how it is played castle now I think I
was at a cost lots of time you know to
him to remember to remember the lines I
think this is right but it took me took
me far too long to to remember can I go
Bishop a five year in this position
Bishop f5 I should be five Bishop see to
do something like that why is that
entirely crazy doesn't look crazy 55
bishop sea to fish about Sandra graphs
on it should be pretty decent
compensation ok check okay let's not
play that too quickly even though I
think this is no good and anything I
could still cancel thing for a moment
and 23 was my intended move of course
but no I 93 this route you one yeah then
to know great idea that's still a
theoretical position that that's that's
that's insane or you just plays instant
moose as like all the time
ecigs a playbook f2 rougarou Bishop c5
maybe 93 this one
ruge f8 this Knight f3 maybe okay I
could go nite f4 in this position and
just annoy him like that rookie three
Bishop c5 looks bad okay for the way I
can go before but let's go up to eight
cannot move the night now and at least
this be four square for the night is
also blocked not easy to play
Bishop c5 is also potentially good move
so we place that any way out it is not
prevented look you one check check so 92
inches goes King everyone yeah great
great check so well let's check here
checking f1 and let's put the bish
allowed should be three is not possible
couple of interesting things Knight f3
maybe just right then i can play night
age three and finally get stuff back I
didn't think of that at all ah Jesus
he's got 93 he's getting away with that
with that stuff remarkable check okay
wait kind of wondering here is that so
great that's right I don't
I cannot go should be 60 unfortunately
it's coming with Knight a5 honey
midnight a five of all moves okay write
a five was much check much more testing
I think
check I still can't fight a little bit
Jerry even though should be winning by
now check
check black resins someone frustrating
that this should should work and i know
i have got pretty pretty big
compensation here but i couldn't
couldn't really make it work chan chan
yeah I just completely did not I didn't
think of Bishop f4 I simply didn't think
of it it's a pretty awful awful mistake
you can probably improve before it even
here this should be ok i don't i don't
think i can go push away three ma'am if
you have to look earlier I mean okay
what I know is that this is an ok line I
mean I think I'm know I actually had
this takes takes me three that is not
okay so maybe this is right check this
is this some some improvement awesome I
don't know Queen f5
he the engine gives rupee aid yeah it is
pretty interesting so 94 is so just
dropping that pole and so Knight f3 and
then Bishop d6 TI get it back very
comfortably check
check
Kim Possible me why despite a ham it's
very possible Chad here definitely I
mean okay the rook traders this is just
a mistaken and I'm not quite assure here
I really thought that I should I could
could be okay in this end game and g5
and g5 okay the engine give this as
equal i mean i'm not talking nonsense
here trading in to Bishop against night
was a pretty bad idea but i am here
getting the porn back yeah i was in 95
now I kinky it was actually right check
check sure nothing to do yeah those
those sight lines can be very tricky and
lets you spend like one minute one and a
half minute and he cannot quite remember
how it works and he blitz it out you had
to move 15 or so that that wacky line
it's a scissors incredibly probably that
popular in blitz I should really refresh
my memory there okay thanks for watching